in this video we're going to go through
10 examples where we verify
trigonometric identities so see if you
can pause the video and try some of
these problems on your own or go through
all of them together and at the end of
the video I'll show you a little bit
more about where some of these trig
identities come from so you can
understand it at a little bit deeper
level if you're interested in that so
let's dive into the first example A 1
over secant x plus one minus 1 over
secant x minus 1 is equal to negative 2
cotangent squared of X so how can we
basically prove that this is an identity
meaning that the left side and the right
side are identical to one another well
the first thing you want to do is you
want to pick the side that's more
expanded it's a little bit bigger and
it's a little bit easier to work with
that more expanded side and then
condense it down to the side that's more
condensed so in this case it looks like
the left side is a little bit more
expanded so what we're going to do is
we're going to try to combine these
together into one fraction notice
there's like two groups here we only
have one group here so to do that we're
going to get a common denominator so
over here I'm going to multiply this
fraction by secant x minus 1.
and I'm going to do that to the
numerator and the denominator
to keep the you know fraction the same
and the same thing over here I'm going
to multiply this fraction by secant x
plus one
to the numerator and denominator
and so now if we do that you can see
we're going to end up with
secant x minus 1 over now when I
multiply this together I'm going to get
secant squared x minus 1 because
notice this is a sum and difference
pattern when you foil this out the
inside secant x and negative secant x
are going to cancel you're just going to
end up with secant squared minus 1 and
then same thing over here with this
fraction we're going to end up with
secant x plus one
all over the common denominator of
secant squared x minus 1.
and again we're trying to prove that
it's equal to this negative 2 cotangent
squared of X so we're just going to work
with this one side and show that it
equals that right side so now that we
have a common denominator we can go
ahead and subtract these numerators so
secant minus secant that's zero negative
1 minus 1 that's going to give us
negative 2 over secant squared x minus
1. now when I see these trig functions
to the second power like squared I like
to think of these Pythagorean trig
identities as possibly being able to
help me and I notice here that 1 plus
tangent squared equals secant squared
but if I subtract 1 from both sides of
this equation secant squared minus 1 is
going to equal tangent squared
so this is going to really be negative 2
divided by tangent squared of X and then
you want to use your reciprocal
identities these ones you already know
like 1 over tangent is cotangent 1 over
tangent squared would be equal to
cotangent squared so this comes out to
negative 2
cotangent squared x and you can see they
match we proved it see if you can pause
the video and do example number two here
we have sine to the fourth x times sine
x cosine x minus sine squared x times
sine x cosine x equals negative sine
cubed x cosine Cube X how would you do
that one
well one thing to notice is the left
side is much more expanded than the
right side so let's go ahead and work
with this left side see if we can
condense it down and what I would do on
this one is I'd recognize that I have
like two groups this group and this
group separated by this minus sign and
when we're doing these trig identities
oftentimes you'll find that it's just
like doing algebra or with trig
functions and so what we can do is we
can actually do some factoring so I
notice that I've got a sine x cosine X
in both groups I also have a sine
squared x that I can factor out so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to do like
the distributive property backwards I'm
going to factor out a sine squared x
sine x cosine X
and I'm going to factor that out of this
group right here
and this group right here so if I factor
it out what will I be left with well
I'll be left with sine squared
and over here
I'm factoring that whole quantity out so
I'm just left with minus 1.
okay so now what can we do well again
when I see these ones to the second
power like this squared I think of the
Pythagorean trig identities sine squared
minus 1. okay let's see so sine squared
If I subtract 1 to the left side of the
equation subtract the cosine squared x
to the right side sine squared minus 1
is going to equal the negative cosine
squared of X so we can replace this
quantity here with negative
cosine squared x
so now
let's see what we have we have sine
squared times sine to the first that's
going to give us sine cubed x
cosine times cosine squared when you
multiply you add the exponents 2 plus 1
gives us cosine cubed x times a negative
1 gives us a negative sine cubed x
cosine cubed x and that's what we were
trying to prove so in this example it
was more of like a factoring example in
addition to using the Pythagorean trig
identity okay see if you can try number
three go ahead and pause the video we've
got 1 plus sine X over cosine X plus
cosine X over 1 plus sine X we're trying
to prove that equals 2 secant x so
you're probably noticing a pattern here
most of the time we're condensing the
left side of the equation to equal the
right side but it can be the reverse but
in this case looks like the left side is
more expanded
you notice we have two groups just one
group over here so let's see if we can
combine these into one fraction by
getting a common denominator so here it
looks like the common denominator is
going to be the two of these
denominators multiplied together so what
I mean by that is this one has a cosine
X but it's missing a 1 plus sine X so
let's go ahead and multiply that
numerator and the denominator by what
it's missing which is that one plus sine
X
okay now over here it's missing a cosine
so let's multiply the numerator and
denominator by cosine X and let's see
what we get so here I'm going to leave
the denominator in factored form so this
is just going to end up being
cosine X
times 1 plus sine X
in the numerator we're going to have to
distribute so we've got one
times one is one plus one times sine is
sine X sine X times 1 is another sine X
sine X times sine X is sine squared x
okay plus we have the same denominator
here 1 plus sine X
cosine X
and then we multiply the numerators
together we get cosine squared x now
because we have the same denominator we
can combine these into one fraction with
a common denominator so what I'm going
to do here is I'm just going to
make this into one fraction
with this common denominator okay so now
let's look at what we have here we have
sine squared plus cosine squared
which is equal to one so what I can do
is I can combine this sine squared plus
cosine squared equal to one we've got
one plus one which is equal to two plus
sine X Plus sine X which is 2 sine X
all over our common denominator
cosine x times 1 plus sine X now notice
we could factor out a 2 out of both of
these groups here and the way that would
look is it would be 2 times 1 plus sine
X
all over our common denominator
cosine X
1 plus sine X and you can see that these
are going to cancel numerator and
denominator the 1 plus sine X we're left
with 2 over cosine X and remember 1 over
cosine is secant so 2 over cosine is
going to be equal to
2 secant x which is what we were trying
to prove that it's equal to okay before
we dive into problem number four here we
need to have a little bit of a heart to
heart okay so if you stuck with me this
far I want to start sharing some little
motivations and hopefully helpful hints
here to help you to understand these
identities I know it can be frustrating
for some students it's like what are you
doing Mario what is all of this right
remember an identity means that it's
identical two things are identical if
they're identical you can swap one for
the other okay that's all that we're
really doing I'm going to show you where
a lot of these trig identities come from
at the end of this video if you want to
stick around for that but the key thing
to remember is that what we're doing is
like algebra but with trig functions
okay so you've already seen me do
getting common denominators we did that
in algebra one right you saw me do
factoring we did that in algebra one
right so we're just doing basically
algebra with trig functions the other
thing that you want to pay attention to
is that you may not have seen a
particular type of problem before I may
be showing you this similar type problem
when you see a problem that's like that
again in the future you're going to
already have some familiarity you're
going to kind of know what to do but I'm
going to share with you what another
teacher that I had before shared with me
and that's that if you don't know what
to do
just make sure that you do something you
can't make a mistake as long as the two
quantities are identical you can make a
substitution and you're eventually going
to get to what it is that you're trying
to prove it might take you a few extra
steps big deal right obviously want to
get there faster if we can but if it
takes a few more steps no problem so let
me show you another example hang with us
here you just have to keep practicing
it's going to get easier so let's do
number four
notice in this problem we've got sine of
negative X this is what we call an even
odd identity the sine of negative X is
equal to negative sine of x so let's
make that substitution this is equal to
negative sine of x so we're going to
have cosine X in the numerator over 1
minus sine of x in the denominator now
we're trying to get it to look like this
right
what I'm going to do now is going to
seem completely out of the blue but
you're going to understand in a minute
we've got this 1 minus sine of x we're
going to multiply by what we call the
conjugate remember when you rationalized
fractions that had radicals in them like
square roots and you multiplied by the
conjugate so I'm changing the sign from
minus to plus but these two terms are
the same whatever I do to the
denominator have to do to the numerator
so I don't change the overall value of
the fraction
so what happens here in the numerator
I'm just going to distribute
okay actually let's hear let's see
should I distribute yeah let's
distribute so that's going to be cosine
X plus cosine X sine X right in the
denominator we have a sum and difference
pattern which means that the inside
negative sine X and the outside positive
sine X those are going to cancel out
we've got 1 times 1 which is 1 and
negative sine X times positive sine X is
negative sine squared x so you can foil
that out or do the distributive property
twice
and so now we've got 1 minus sine
squared x when I see the ones with the
second degree now it's not always this
way but a lot of times it's a
Pythagorean trig identity and you can
see if I subtract sine squared x to the
right side of this equation 1 minus sine
squared x is equal to cosine squared x
so let's go ahead and replace this with
cosine squared x so this is going to
look like cosine X Plus
cosine X sine X all divided by
cosine squared x now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to split this up into
two fractions cosine x divided by cosine
squared x
and cosine X sine X divided by cosine
squared x so if I do that
let me write it over here now so we're
running out of space so cosine over
cosine squared one of these cosines
actually let's do it in steps so we
don't confuse anybody so cosine X over
cosine squared x okay plus
cosine x times sine X all divided by
cosine squared x okay so that's all we
did is we split it up into two fractions
with the same denominator one of these
cosines cancels with one of these
cosines leaving us with one over cosine
X over here one of these cosines cancels
with one of these cosines leaving us
with sine X over cosine X now we know
the reciprocal of cosine one over cosine
that's equal to secant x
sine over cosine this is our quotient
identity that's equal to tangent X
and you can see that's what we're trying
to prove here
secant x plus tangent X and you got it
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number five on your own
here we have sine of pi over 2 minus X
Plus 1 all over one plus cosine of the
negative X and we're trying to show that
equals one so if I was going to do this
problem I would notice I've got this pi
over 2 minus X that's a cofunction sine
of pi over 2 minus X is equal to the
cosine of x so we can replace this whole
quantity here with cosine of x
plus one and then over here we have 1
plus cosine of negative X that's an even
odd identity cosine of negative X is
just equal to the same as cosine of
positive X so this whole thing is going
to be 1 plus cosine of positive X okay
now you can see that addition is
commutative right so cosine X Plus 1 is
the same as 1 plus cosine X
anything divided by itself is equal to
1. so you can see one is equal to 1 and
we proved it okay see if you can pause
the video and do number six this one
let's see we've got sine X times
cosecant X over 1 plus cotangent squared
x and we're trying to show it equals
sine squared of x
so I notice I've got this cotangent
squared of X and usually when I see the
ones that are squared I think of the
Pythagorean trig identities one plus
cotangent squared is equal to the
cosecant square root of x so we can
replace this with cosecant squared x
and then cosecant of X we know that
cosecant of X is equal to 1 over the
sine of x okay
those that's the reciprocal identity so
sine of x this sine of x you can think
of as like sine of x over one so
numerator and denominator that cancels
that's going to give us just one in the
numerator over cosecant squared x in the
denominator and we know that sine and
cosecant are reciprocals of each other 1
over cosecant is sine one over cosecant
squared is equal to sine squared x and
we proved it
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number seven cosecant x minus
cotangent x times cosine X is equal to
the sine of x so how would you prove
that one
well let's see if I was going to do this
one I know that cosecant is the
reciprocal of sine so this is the same
as 1 over sine X
I know that cotangent using this
quotient identity is equal to cosine X
over sine X
cosine X which is kind of like cosine
over one because anything divided by 1
is itself
so now let's see we've got a common
denominator see sine X sine X so I could
really write this as one fraction with
sine X as our denominator and this is
going to be 1 minus cosine squared x
okay now I see the one with the second
degree the squared
1 minus cosine squared x If I subtract
the cosine squared x to the right side
of the equation that would be equal to
sine squared x so this numerator is sine
squared x over sine X one of these sine
squareds in the numerator cancels with
one of the signs in the denominator
leaving us with just sine X which is
what we were trying to prove and you got
it
okay see if you can do number eight
we've got cosecant x times cosine X over
cotangent X Plus tangent X and we're
showing trying to show it equals cosine
squared x now before you dive into that
one I just want to give you another hint
sometimes students
they say well Mario how did you know to
use a particular identity right well if
you ever get stuck
you can always convert things back into
Sines and cosines everything is built up
of Sines and cosines okay those are the
basic building blocks so you could go
back to Sines and cosines and if you're
not sure what to do and take it from
that angle and that's what I'm going to
do in this problem so I've got cosecant
of X which is really like 1 over sine of
x cosine cosecant our reciprocals cosine
X is just cosine over one because
anything divided by 1 is itself
cotangent X from our quotient identities
is cosine X
over sine X
and tangent X from our quotient identity
is sine X over cosine X okay so let's
simplify down what we have here we've
got
cosine over sine
for our numerator cosine X over sine X
and then in our denominator we want to
get a common denominator so it looks
like this one is missing a cosine so
let's multiply
the numerator and denominator by cosine
the X and over here we're missing a sine
so let's multiply the numerator and
denominator by
sine X so if we do that we get cosine
squared X Plus sine squared x over our
common denominator of cosine X sine X
okay now this is interesting so when you
have a fraction divided by another
fraction
it's like multiplying by the reciprocal
so you keep the numerator let's just go
up here for a little bit more room so
cosine X
over sine X that's our numerator we're
going to multiply by the reciprocal of
the denominator which is cosine X
sine X
and then over cosine squared plus sine
squared but what's cosine squared plus
sine squared equal to
1 that's our Pythagorean trig identity
okay so now
let's see what we have we have sine X in
the denominator cancels with sine X in
the numerator cosine x times cosine X is
cosine squared x
all over one anything divided by 1 is
itself and we proved that it's equal to
cosine squared x okay see if you can do
number nine we've got secant squared x
minus tangent squared X Plus cotangent
squared x all over 1 minus cosine
squared x and we're trying to show that
it equals cosecant to the fourth power
of x
so how would you do that one
well I notice I have a lot of squares
here so when I think of the ones to the
second power think of the Pythagorean
trig identities
and over here you can see secant squared
minus tangent squared If I subtract
tangent squared to the right side of the
equation
secant squared minus tangent squared is
equal to 1. so I can replace this whole
thing right here
with one so that gives us 1 plus
cotangent squared x over 1 minus cosine
squared x now if I subtract the cosine
squared x 1 minus cosine squared x is
going to equal sine squared x
okay so it's a little bit more condensed
1 plus cotangent squared x is equal to
cosecant squared x
so another Pythagorean trig identity
and here's the other hint that I want to
offer you and that's that you want to
keep one eye on the right side you got
to know kind of where you're headed
right and the other eye on the side that
you're working on so as you're doing
this you're trying to think well I need
to condense this somehow obviously this
is pretty condensed but I also kind of
you know use this as a guide it's
basically like they're giving us the
answer we know where we're headed so we
just have to keep our eye on where we're
headed here
so now it looks like I'm trying to get
the cosecant to the fourth I've got
cosecant squared but I also have this
sine squared now sine and cosecant are
reciprocals of each other right you want
to remember sine is equal to 1 over
cosecant X but
if I have a sine squared that's going to
equal to
1 over cosecant squared so that's what
I'm going to do I'm going to replace the
sine squared
with what it's equal to which is 1 over
cosecant squared x now when you divide
by a fraction it's like multiplying by
the reciprocal right so this is really
going to be
cosecant squared x that's our numerator
over 1 times the reciprocal of the
denominator which is one whoops
that's actually
cosecant squared over 1. so cosecant
cosecant squared x over 1. and you can
see cosecant squared times cosecant
squared is going to give us cosecant to
the fourth of X all divided by one
anything divided by 1 is itself and we
proved it
okay we've made it to the last problem
so see if you can do number 10 on your
own we'll go through it together
again it takes a lot of practice you
want to do a lot of these problems to
get good at them so if you want more
practice I'm going to have another video
at the end of this video that I'm going
to reference talking about simplifying
and verifying trig identities I go
through 14 examples in that video so you
want to check that out and I'm also
going to talk about how to understand
some of these trig identities a little
bit better like I promised at the
beginning so we'll do that also after
this problem but let's dive into the
last example we're trying to show that
this is equal to four tangent squared X
plus two so what would you do in this
problem well to me if I'm squaring
something that means that I'm
multiplying it times itself so this is
really like
tangent x minus secant x times itself so
another tangent x minus secant x you
might know the formula for squaring a
binomial but just some people they kind
of forgot so you might want to just
write that twice so tangent X Plus
secant x times another
tangent X
plus secant x right so you can foil or
you can distribute twice so tangent
times tangent gives us tangent squared
tangent times negative secant x gives us
a negative secant x tangent X then
negative secant x times tangent X is
another negative secant x tangent X I'm
going to write negative 2 okay and then
negative secant x times negative secant
x is positive secant squared x okay now
over here if we distribute tangent times
tangent is
tangent squared tangent times secant is
secant tangent and another secant
tangent which is two secant x tangent X
and secant times secant is secant
squared x okay so now let's see we can
combine a little bit tangent squared
plus tangent squared
is going to give us
tangent squared x
and negative 2 secant x tangent X and
positive 2 secant x tangent X those
actually cancel because one is negative
one is positive and then we have secant
squared X Plus another secant squared x
which is 2
secant squared x
okay now remember we want to keep one
eye on the right side we want it to look
like this four tangent squared X plus
two we've got two tangents squared x
how are we going to get rid of the
secant squared x well secant squared x
is equal to 1 plus tangent squared x so
let's go ahead and replace this
with 1 plus
tangent squared x and let's bring this
down to tangent squared x we'll
distribute the 2 so that's two plus two
tangent squared x bring this down to
tangent squared x so two tangent squared
X plus two tangent squared x is four
tangent squared X plus 2 and that's what
we were trying to prove and you got it
so great job if you're able to get all
those again we're going to talk about
how to do some of these identities or
where they come from and if you want
more practice go to the end of this
video and check out that other trig
identity video that I talk about where
we go through 14 examples so now on to
the explanation of where some of these
trig identities come from you know it's
not absolutely necessary to know where
they come from I mean they're identical
you can always interchange one quantity
for another and a lot of students are
fine with just you know knowing that
right but sometimes I find that if you
understand where it comes from
you have all these formulas but really
when you understand it you almost don't
even have to memorize the formulas
because it will make sense to you we're
all you know where all this comes from
and why it is and if you click if you
forget one of the formulas you can
quickly you know remember why what the
formula is so let's
keep going if you're still here with me
so remember on the unit circle it's a
circle with radius of unit one and if
you locate a point like right X up y
That's the coordinates of the point and
say for example if you wanted to figure
out like what's the sine of theta sine
of this angle well you remember from the
trigonometry and even geometry the sine
is the ratio of the opposite side over
the hypotenuse so we say sine is y over
one but anything divided by 1 is itself
so on the unit circle we say the sine is
equal to the y coordinate of the the
point right and the cosine of the angle
is the adjacent side
over the hypotenuse that's X over 1 but
anything divided by one is just itself
so that's X and then the tangent
we know is equal to the opposite over
adjacent so that's equal to Y over X now
a tangent being y over X remember
tangent I'm sorry Y is equal to the sine
and cosine is equal to the X so tangents
really like the sine divided by the
cosine so that's where this is coming
from okay and of course the cotangent we
know cotangent and tangent are
reciprocals of one another so that's how
you're getting the cosine over the sine
now for the Pythagorean tree identities
we know that uh a squared plus b squared
equals c squared right so you have x
squared plus y squared is equal to 1
squared which is one but again we've
already established that the cosine is
the X so that's really cosine squared
and sine is the Y so that's really equal
to sine squared
is equal to 1. so that's our Pythagorean
trig identity this first one
but if we were to divide all these by
cosine squared we're doing it to the
left side and the right side to keep the
equation balanced right
what happens we get cosine squared over
cosine squared is equal to 1 plus sine
squared over cosine squared is equal to
tangent squared and 1 over cosine
squared is equal to secant squared if
you were to divide all of these by sine
squared you would get let's see you'd
get 1 plus cotangent squared is equal to
cosecant squared so as long as you
divide them all by sine squared or all
by cosine squared to get the other two a
Pythagorean trig identities
okay now for the cofunctions let's look
at this a little bit closer so see if
you have a right triangle like this
say if this angle is Theta this angle
has to be 90 minus Theta or in radians
that's pi over 2 minus Theta now just
follow me for a moment here so see if
this is a b and c so if I say what's the
uh sine of theta that would be opposite
over hypotenuse right so sine of theta
is a over C what happens if I do the
cosine of 90 minus Theta that's the
adjacent over the hypotenuse that's also
a over C so you can see that
cosine of 90 minus Theta is the same as
sine of theta and you'll see that's the
true for all these cofunctions the sine
and cosine go together the tangent and
cotangent go together the secant and
cosecant go together and the reason is
you're switching positions on this
triangle like if you're over here and
you're saying like oh what's the tangent
that's opposite of a hypotenuse but then
if you switch to this so that was A over
B right so if you switch to this angle
you say what's the cotangent of 90 minus
Theta that's adjacent over opposite
That's A over B and you can see they're
equivalent but you're changing you know
the angle that you're working with to
the other acute angle so that's where
the cofunction identities come from and
then or a way to understand it at least
and then the even odd identities is like
this so we go on our unit circle we go
this direction it's a positive angle
when we go clockwise it's a negative
angle so if I could drew the same
triangle down here and say I make this a
negative Theta this Dimension here would
still be X this dimension on this
triangle is going to be a negative Y and
then the hypotenuse is one so say for
example if I say what's the sine of
theta this positive angle that's
opposite of hypotenuse that's y over 1
that's y but if I do the sine of the
same angle with a negative angle see
sine of negative Theta that's opposite
over hypotenuse that's negative y over
one same y value but it's the opposite
sign so we say sine of a negative angle
is the same as the assignment of the
positive angle multiplied by negative 1.
and you can see that's going to be true
for the cosecant the tangent and the
cotangent but let's look at cosine for a
moment so cosine
is cosine of theta is adjacent over
hypotenuse so cosine is X over one if
you do this angle down here the cosine
of negative Theta it's adjacent over
hypotenuse it's still X over one so we
say that cosine and secant are even okay
functions meaning that the cosine of
negative X is the same as the cosine of
positive X the secant of negative X is
the same as secant of X because remember
secant and cosine are reciprocals of
each other
the odd ones are the sine cosecant
tangent cotangent and you're going to
get the same trig function but it's
multiplied by negative one and you can
understand it from drawing this triangle
so I hope that helps you to understand
some of these identities a little bit
better follow me over to that video
right there where I dive into more
examples of verifying trig identities
and we'll go through 14 examples I'll
see over in that video
great job